Chính phủ mý đã phẩy giám cụ rình và tử người bá mốt thống một sau khi đó hội không kịt thông bóen sách cho tệ khóa
2 nghìn khun sân hay sau, trước thử hạn nửa đế thu chức mẫu sử bà.
Tuy nhiên, giới lập pháp bị cho rằng tình trạng giản đợi này chỉ tụi tại trong thời gian rất ngắn,
sau ở nâng sách đã được tưởng ruyện thông qua và hạn vệ dự kiến sẽ nhóm hoặc trở lại vào ngày 12.
Tổng thống đơn là trong thiu gọi hạn vệ nhân trọng hình đông, nhằm chẳng đề tình trạng đống cụ kêu dài,
ông bây tổ hi vọng cả hai đàn cụ hoa và rất trụ sẽ bỏ phía uống vụ có thể thuật mang tính lượng đàn ngày.
Vịt đông cụ chính phủ mượt phần anh vượng đến khoảng 3 tưởng hạn đông của chính phủ liên băng,
bao ngồn các lĩnh vực giám sục ý tế nhà ử vào có phòng.
Nếu hạn vệnh thông qua và nguyên sách vào đồ tình tới,
môn tài trợ sẽ được khó phục trong bòng và ngày,
qua đó hạn chế tất tổng của tình trạng chính phủ đông cụ.
Nếu thời gian đông cụ kéo dài hơn, hàng trục nguyên nhân viên băng,
ông ý cơ phải gỷ việc không luôn, phó k làm việc mà chưa được chi trạng ai.
Đây là lần thứ 2 chính phủ mỹ động cơ một phần trong hiện kiện thứ 2 của tổng thống trám.